So I want to start today with some stories from the newspapers.
Set a tone,
a terror.
There's over the last few years,
Tehran,
one afternoon Fatuma Eskandari opened the front metal gate of the shelter.
She runs for runaway girls in central Tehran and was confronted with two men
armed with knives and rifles.
Who are you?
She asked.
We are the uncles who have a girl named [inaudible].
We are told that you are keeping runner and indeed that's true.
Runak was 16 years old and she was inside recovering from the bruises that she
suffered at the hands of these same uncles.
She had run away from home to escape them.
The uncles had driven from Sana and die in the northwest corner of Iran,
hundreds of miles away.
They demanded to see their knees.
The uncle said she had shamed the family by leaving home a few days before they
had come to behead her.
They're very open about this.
There was no secret
Staten Island New York.
The 17 year old girl worked as a cashier in a convenience store.
The store owner said that the girl was stealing from the register and he was
going to fire her.
The girl went to her father and said that the store owner had groped her.
The father flew into a rage,
grabbed the baseball bat and a gun,
went down to the store and killed two people.
Islam about Pakistan,
so he did.
Purveen 21 years old,
was pregnant in 1998 when her husband Mukmood kickball bound her hands and feet
with the rope.
First he shoved a rod in one of her eyes,
blinding her,
then cut off her nose and ears.
He suspected her of seeing another man,
Tuscaloosa,
Alabama.
Felicia Scott already had two sons,
but she had an obsessive desire to have another baby.
She convinced her boyfriend to help her get one,
so they went out,
shot a pregnant woman and cut the full term fetus from her womb.
Saudi Arabia,
New York Times.
A young woman was raped by seven men.
She pressed charges.
The Saudi court sentenced her to 200 lashes,
200 lashes,
almost a lethal dose.
Dominican Republic.
Cressida Mendina is 18 she's been married for a year in which her husband,
Jose,
beat her content constantly.
She had the courage to separate from him,
but she met with Jose after their separation.
When he asked her to talk,
he took her to a desolate street on his motorcycle and they had an argument.
He grabbed a container he had filled with what they called the devil's acid,
a mixture of gasoline,
hydrochloric acid,
car battery,
a car battery,
acid,
urine,
and other chemicals.
He threw it at Cruceta liquid disfigured her permanently.
It burned her face,
her arms,
the right side of her chest and a portion of her legs.
She is still trying to bring her ex husband to justice.
Casara gone.
Bangladesh.
I'm almost done with this.
The village elders met,
met under Leechy tree to put a value on Pieara becomes good grotesquely ruined
face.
A young man had become obsessed with her,
but she was married and he was turned away.
He took his revenge will sulfuric acid to erase the beauty that had once
enchanted him and to empty her life of happiness.
Her cheeks smelted her right.
I was a blonde,
blinded in hollow to a crater.
The husband had to bribe the prosecutors before they would even take up the
case.
Eventually the perpetrator's family had to pay a fee of $3,000
in one year than a number of the year.
I have statistics for 1999 there were 174 acid attacks in Bangladesh.
Those are the ones that were officially reported.
Of course,
probably the vast majority of these never get reported.
The article mentioned the 13 year old girl who was attacked her,
she slept.
Some victims die.
Some are forced to marry their attacker.
Another was forbidden to come home until she allowed her husband to take a
second wife.
Well,
these stories are obviously,
uh,
at the extreme of human behavior,
but the purpose of,
of giving you all that is to explain that human sexual behavior has extremely
deep roots,
very emotional,
and very hard to,
to change or manipulate male female relationships are very difficult for humans
to cope with.
And I think it shouldn't particularly surprise you that human sexuality is not
particularly driven by rational calculation.
This few,
the few stories that I pulled out of the newspapers,
uh,
I just,
the tip clearly just a tip of an iceberg of a very widespread phenomenon in the
long course of human history across cultures.
You see the art,
the gave you everything in Brooklyn to Bangladesh.
Uh,
these very similar sorts of things happen,
uh,
females through the long course of history.
And in most cultures where most humans have lived a,
females are treated very badly.
There's a huge amount of battering.
Battering is the time human version of,
of violence and females are so discriminated against that statistics indicate
that there's something now,
right now something like a hundred million missing females,
that these females are either a boarded before they're born,
killed by infanticide pretty as soon as they're born or neglected,
so that they don't get the food or they don't get their medical care that
they're brothers get.
So there's a dearth of something like 100 million women in the world today.
And uh,
so these are not,
these are,
these are extreme incidents,
but it's an extremely common,
uh,
thing.
And one of the purposes of this course is to try to get you to understand what,
what is causing all of this from a biological point of view.
Uh,
this abusive females is extremely weird.
males as you know,
can only reproduce via a female.
And so,
and evolution is the name of the game is reproducing.
So almost all species,
what kind of a female to the males want,
they want the healthiest,
most well protected,
the best fed female.
And you'll see some examples of the extremes to which males will go to,
to provide this so that that female can produce offspring for that mail and
carry on the evolution game.
But in humans,
we find that it's very general that females are treated Shosha slee and it's
just doesn't make sense that that human males should keep many of their females
hungry,
sick and,
and abused.
And if child birth,
if a woman does give birth to a child,
that can often be underweight,
a sickly and so forth,
because the mother is not in great health.
So this is all the biological disaster of the way human males treat human
females.
And,
uh,
we don't know why.
I mean we do,
we have some idea why humans do that.
And the first part of the course,
we'll talk something about that that's on the individual level and evolution
works on an individual level.
But if you think on a species level missing 100 million of your,
of your breeders,
that does not sound like a great tactic for survival of the species.
So I spent some time when I started getting interested in this whole topic,
uh,
reading,
the anthropological literature,
the sociological literature,
the feminist literature.
And basically I thought all of those explanations where a crock,
and I don't think they came close to,
to an answer.
So in my own studies,
I had to go back to the very beginning and understand what sex was really all
about.
So I'm going to tell you a few important things about sex and reproduction.
The first one is that reproduction turns out to be very difficult.
So one day I was sitting over in the our botanical garden under one beautiful
big huge oak tree that they have.
And the ground was kind of this covered with Acorns,
uh,
under this tree.
And uh,
I asked one of the forestry people,
cause that's the kind of things that they know.
I asked them how many acorns does this tree produced?
And they said,
well,
the wind of the spread is so much and it's this high and you know,
and so deep.
And they came up probably 750,000 acorns a year.
I thought,
wow.
So I checked the literature and
found that the people that collect these notes for commercial purposes,
a good oak tree can produce 500 pounds of acorns a year.
And many sources say that an oak tree produces millions of acorns in its
lifetime.
Wow.
Lot of reproduction,
right?
Got To be sex before.
And then I asked myself,
how many of these million acorns survive to make a tree like their parents?
What's the answer?
I think basic biology course,
you might know it.
Well,
what if each tree on average,
taking an average of truth made to acorns?
How many acorns would there be?
How many oak trees would they be in the neck?
May to acorns that made trees.
How many oak trees would there be in the next generation?
Twice as many as now.
What if they only did?
And so that can't continue because then the earth would immediately fill up with
oak trees and we'd be,
you know,
this deep in,
in acorns.
And similarly,
if they,
if the trees produce less on average,
less than one,
what will happen to the oak species goes extinct.
So over the long time,
on average,
each oak tree has only one acorn that grows up to be a,
uh,
an acorn producing tree itself.
That's an amazing duction puts out in millions of acorns that only one survives.
And of course this is true not only for,
for trees,
but a fish which spew out,
you know,
fish,
females,
huge numbers.
Thousand 500,
tens of thousands,
hundreds of thousands of eggs or,
or males of many,
many species that spilled billions of sperms that in a sexual species,
the way Amazon to parents on average two children,
if two parents for a species average more than two children,
the world fills up with squirrels or whatever animal talking about if they have
less than two over a long run,
they've gone extinct.
Most species in fact in the history have gone extinct.
So the average of current species has got to be one for one or two for two,
depending on how you count.
But for most species,
it's less than less than that because most species have gone extinct.
So the answer is it is brutally difficult to reproduce.
Um,
if any given individual in a species produces a lot of children,
more than one or two,
depending on how you're counting,
uh,
then that means that some other individuals are having less.
Again,
unless the species of humans,
which are about the only species that are increasing continuously over the long
time as an example,
they now buy this genetic testing,
have tested how many descendants does gangas Colin have?
And the answer is 16 million descendants.
This one guy.
So that's an awful lot.
But guess how he did it by killing a lot of men and raping their women.
So he,
he has that many descendants,
goes an awful lot of men.
All the men he killed don't have any descendants.
And that's just is con the Mongol Hoard,
had a lot of males and I think they spread their seeds quite widely and a lot of
males in conquered people just didn't,
didn't survive.
So,
and of course,
every army in the world,
uh,
has done it all,
essentially all have done a huge amount of raping.
And it's a wonderful instrument of gene flow in the human population.
So because reproduction is actually so difficult,
species have evolved all kinds of fantastic mechanisms,
uh,
for trying to be successful reproduction.
So that's 0.1.
Point two is that sex is not fair.
It's not only difficult,
but it's not fair.
So sex goes way back and evolution
and even bacteria do it.
So this is the biologist here are laughing.
This is uh,
the bacteria that are in your colon and they have sex in this manner.
And so right now,
billions of sexual acts are taking place in your unspeakable parts.
And this is the way they do it.
Now,
I don't have to go back a little bit in something like this.
Actually can the,
the,
the exchange of DNA can be either way.
And this is even though the hairy guy on the left is producing that long pilots
as it's called,
uh,
there's more or less he quality of sexuality,
here.
But when it comes to higher organisms,
you get quite a different story.
You all know,
sure.
The chicken and the egg.
Well,
the way I tell it is the poor chicken,
the chicken has to uh,
build this big egg has to eat like crazy,
put all that protein and fat into the egg,
which are,
if you're not fed in the Barnyard,
which are hard to come by.
And then once the chicken is hatched,
guess who sits with the egg comes out.
Guess who sits on the egg?
The female guests who protects the young,
the female.
So that's chickens.
You can go all the way up to humans.
Females have to spend my nine months pregnant.
And then in most societies and most times,
uh,
females are the ones that have the burden of responsibility for the children.
Meanwhile,
in all this,
uh,
males just produce a little speck of protoplasm inserted into the female and
say,
bye bye.
I've had my quickie and I'm off.
And not in all species,
but in most species,
the male has a very minimal part in reproduction and the has this huge burden.
Now why does that come about?
And you'd think evolution would,
would require that females just wouldn't play this game in evolution and they
would require a more equal distribution of the Labor?
Well,
it turns out it is a starts as a division of labor.
So the first animals to evolve,
first of anything,
we're probably almost certainly in the sea and stuck down on the bottom,
are floating around.
And so they couldn't move.
And so how do you mate,
if you can't get up and find your mate?
Well you just spew out your sperms into the ocean.
You spew out your eggs into the ocean and you hope that they meet.
Not a very,
very,
not a very efficient mechanisms.
But at that stage,
uh,
the male has produced millions of sperms and the female has to produce millions
of eggs.
If you're an animal and you have to produce so many of anything of gametes,
in this case,
each one is going to be very tiny.
Two tiny things,
meet and fuse,
you still got a tiny thing and the odds of survival of a tiny thing in a not
very great.
So evolution doesn't like that idea of the male and the female both spewing out
lots and lots of these tiny gametes.
So what happens eventually is that the two sexes separate that the female's job
is to make a big enough egg with enough nutrient in it so that the organism can
survive.
And the male's job is to go find that egg.
And so what do males have?
Sort of what are the sperms evolve tales to take them swimming,
right?
And as,
and they find their job is to find the agonist.
So there still has to be lots of those and they have to expend a lot of energy,
uh,
swimming.
So it's still an equal amount of,
of investment.
But then the whole animal,
once evolution proceeds,
the whole animal can now get up and walk over and find a female or vice versa.
And now they can copulate or do some sort of insemination very close together.
This now does not require zillions and zillions of sperms.
So He,
if you're,
if the egg say already laid like a fish in a nest in the mail,
just lays the sperms right on top of the eggs and he needs some surplus over the
number of eggs,
but nothing to compensate for the amount of energy she's putting into her eggs.
So you start getting an inequality.
As soon as animals can find each other and mate in a more spatially enclosed
way,
then you start getting any quality.
So
evolution goes down that path because it's turned out to be a very,
very effective path.
And what you get is that females make a eggs.
Her eggs are very expensive,
they are expensive and rare mail's still make many,
many sperms.
His berms are plentiful and cheap.
So this is what we call a sexual dimorphism,
that males and females are taking different evolutionary roots.
And once they take different evolutionary roots,
uh,
then different reproductive strategies come into play for males and females.
So a mail through the first billion years of evolution has been producing a lot
of sperm and now all of a sudden he figures out how to swim over to a female and
he doesn't need all those sperms.
But he's still,
evolution is conservative.
It's still,
he's still producing all of these things.
What is evolution going to do with all those sperms?
But one thing they can do is if he can evolve backwards and just make fewer
sperm,
that would save him some energy.
It would be good for him a little bit,
but it wouldn't really get him an awful lot more children,
which is the name of the evolution game.
Now,
what he can do with those access sperms find another female that his limit,
their there stops being a limit on the number of females that he can seminate.
He spreads his sperm to as many females as he can find.
So
this dimorphism that sperm are cheap and plentiful.
While eggs are expensive and rare leads to different strategies of reproduction
in males and females.
It also sets up some odd situations where for instance,
males are expendable big.
If one male can fertilize a lot of females,
females don't need a lot of males around.
And so for instance,
there's a certain,
uh,
female wasps that lays it's egg and a caterpillar,
Caterpillar,
wasp or one of the major predators of Caterpillar.
They lay the egg in the egg hatches and starts eating up,
uh,
the caterpillar.
So,
but all of the eggs that are laid in a single caterpillar compete with each
other for the food.
Uh,
that is the caterpillar.
So what happens is evolution as arrangement that the females hatch first and
they eat up all their brothers except one.
And then that one male can fertilize all his sisters and,
and things go on.
Uh,
so the males are expendable in that case.
And if the,
the females just ignored them and let them alive,
the males would be competing with the females for food.
The females would grow less big and healthy and they would have less eggs and
have Elucian,
uh,
doesn't like have that kind of a system.
So,
uh,
we'll
all of these things you,
if you think it's not very difficult to find a human examples of this,
uh,
who goes off to war and gets killed
nails.
And very often you don't find any reproductive,
any change in rate.
The females managed to get inseminated human in humans.
So in lots and lots of species,
the number of males is really not a factor in the amount of reproduction
that goes on.
So
males can inseminate many females,
but females want to worry about the survival of each egg and assembly.
Again,
this is pretty obvious,
uh,
in humans that a female,
she gets pregnant,
uh,
is going to be spending nine months pregnant and then breastfeeds and won't get
pregnant again.
So it's at least a year and probably at least a year and a half before that
female can get pregnant again.
And we almost always bear only one child with an occasional twin or so forth.
So very low rate of reproduction where a male doesn't have any,
uh,
such kind of limit.
And
this does not mean that females are monogamous because there's many other
reasons why a female might want to have many mates.
First of all,
we'll see.
She might want to get resources for many males.
You'll see,
she sometimes will not mate with,
uh,
with a,
with a mail list that mail her.
It gives her some resource.
She might want to mate with a variety of males because she can't tell which one
has the best jeans.
She may want to mate with many males if our environment is unpredictable.
And even if she can tell something about his jeans,
she doesn't know what the environment for her children are going to be like.
So she wants to shake up the deck and try have a variety of children with a
variety of different genes.
She might want each mail to think that he's the father of the children so that
he doesn't,
that he protects and doesn't kill the children.
There are species who do that.
Uh,
there's a thing called sperm competition where she may want to have a whole
variety of different sprints from different nails in her and then the sperms
compete.
So even though the sort of a comic book presentation says,
Oh,
males and promiscuous males want to go around and have a lot of sex and females
won't one,
uh,
there's many species with many reasons why female may also want to be
promiscuous.
It used to be believed that many species were in fact,
monogamous birds produced very,
very good example of what you observe is that a male and a female meet at the
beginning of mating season,
they stay together or mating season.
She made me sits on the eggs and he brings worms or some combination thereof and
people that,
well,
this is great,
this is monogamy and what wonderful animals they are.
But now we can do DNA testing and it ain't ain't so that apparently,
uh,
so they call that now social monogamy and distinguish it from sexual monogamy
and probably,
well,
social monogamy is as we've always believed it to be a sexual monogamy is almost
nonexistent.
Uh,
in species when they measure it,
it turns out at 10 to 70% of the progeny have been sired by someone other than
what they called the resident male.
And one article I read claim that there's only one species where does known for
sure that there are 100%,
uh,
sexually monogamous in that case,
the male and female physically fused together.
So neither can go anywhere.
Okay.
So males,
so males have the job of finding and gaining access to females and they have to,
to,
they are basically two strategies.
One is,
uh,
to let their sperms compete.
In that case,
they make this more and better,
uh,
sperm and socially the sexual system.
And a species like that will be promiscuous,
that the females will mate with.
Many males don't have a lot of uh,
semen in their vagina or sperm,
a thicker whatever sack for this.
And then the f the sperms will compete with each other.
And some scientists believe that in humans also we have a variety of sperm
including killer sperm and other kinds of sperm that,
that go in and facilitate this,
find these killer sprint supposed to kill sperm that have a different,
a genotype and it's very controversial.
But whether this,
this is true or not,
the,
the it data starts with when you look at sperm,
they have very human sperm.
They very different shapes and one version as well.
All these other shapes are just damaged.
They're just bad.
You know,
they're not effective.
And there's some evidence for that.
And the other story is that no,
these are doing different jobs and then fertilization and,
uh,
it's a hot area of research.
So that's strategy number one to engage in sperm competition.
And you'll see if we get time that in our related species,
uh,
Benobos chimps are,
are our group of species generally engages in sperm competition.
And what you get is very large testes.
So you can determine this by taking the measure of the weight of testes as a
fraction of total body weight.
And if it's very large,
you know,
this sperm competition going on.
The other strategy of course is males can compete with each other for control of
the females.
And this happens of course in modal motel animals.
Uh,
a sperm competition is the original thing when you're spew out and zillions of
sperms.
And then the best ones fine on the ones that find the females,
but once their modal,
the males can come into contact with each other and they can fight in some way,
uh,
and say control the territory.
For instance,
so a coral reef fish controlled territories in the coral and the female is
cruise around.
Find a male has got a good territory than come and meet with them.
Alternately,
the males will actually fight with each other for dominance and then use that
dominance to gain access.
Females.
So how does this,
what are some examples of how this all works out?
Um,
the females have also two basic strategies.
One is to get the males to provide,
uh,
resources other than,
than sperm.
And those resources allow her to build big healthy eggs.
And one of the really cute examples of this is in the jungle,
uh,
protein nitrogen is very,
very scarce then of the soils are thin and moraines washed everything away.
So it's really hard to get nitrogen.
Guess what's a great source of,
of nitrogen?
Dumb.
Any animal takes a dump in the rain forest immediately.
There's all kinds of,
especially insects that come and are going to utilize that.
Nitrogen is a really scarce resource.
So beetles have are ones that are,
that are very good at this.
And there's a whole group of beetles called Dung Beetles.
And what do they do?
They soon as they detect this by odor probably,
uh,
they come in and start rolling it up into little balls cutting cause it's,
it's much too big for them.
Let me show you a picture.
Come back.
This is a dung beetle and what he's done,
there's a big pad,
a big animal pad nearby,
and he's cut off with his cutting clause,
uh,
this big ball and that's what he's going to present to a female.
So a whole lot of Dung beetles come in.
They make these both then in the species I'm talking about,
they put it on their back and sort of parade around with it.
Meanwhile,
the females are around the outside and they're watching all this go on.
And what males do,
they choose ones are the biggest balls.
So she,
she wants,
she wants resources in,
that's her,
her resource.
Now,
the most extreme case of this is in praying mantises.
So praying mantises beautiful animals,
as you may know,
here's,
here's one of them.
And,
but they're very solitary.
They have to actually catch insect.
They s they sit on the ends of branches and with these claws and they wait for
an insect to fly by and that they grab it and eat it.
It's not an easy,
it's not an easy way to make your living.
So they're poised.
They're very quiet and they want to capture me.
They have just a few milliseconds,
something buzzing.
By now a male comes up and wants to mate with this female,
but she's ready to eat,
so he's got the problem of approaching her and not getting eaten and in
evolution they sometimes get eaten and that has led to a very interesting form
of reproductive strategy that what you see is that the mail will come on and you
can see that that's the Mail on top and look how much smaller he is in the
female.
Then the species,
the male is bigger but he's smaller and that's,
that's a sign that the males are not fighting with each other.
We'll see later that if the male is bigger,
that means they're almost always means they're finding things,
but she's,
because he only has to make sperm.
She has to make eggs.
Notice he has his head still on.
She has her head on.
That's the way it starts and you think that something normal is going to take
place.
When actual fact she reaches around,
grabs him,
she's bigger and stronger than him,
pulls him off and starts eating his head.
And what then happens is she allows him to go back,
but now you can see she's still got her head.
There's no head there.
And the way the insect nervous system has put out the,
all the circuits to coordinate the copulation are down here.
And what the head actually does is inhibit that,
you know,
unless it goes and says,
well,
most situations,
no,
this isn't right to start calculating,
but only in the very special situation where it's a female.
When she eats off his head,
that releases those circuits from inhibition and he calculates her to completion
now and then she can,
when he's done,
she can eat the rest of him.
Now what's really interesting is,
and he doesn't object,
he doesn't try to get away what's going on.
The the,
the key thing is that this is a spar species.
How many of you have seen a praying mantis?
How many have you seen a lot of praying?
Mantises yeah.
One person.
You must study them or something.
They're not hard.
They're not easy to find.
There's not many of them.
So if a male is lucky enough to find a female and getting this situation,
man,
he's in heaven and is unlikely.
If he leaves her,
he's going to find another one that's just an unlikely event.
So how does he maximize this reproduction?
Well,
in my one chance I've got to have that female produce as many eggs with my genes
in it.
So he wants her to produce a lot of big very healthy eggs.
And so his body is the food for her,
including a lot of protein so that she can make a whole lot of eggs and
evolution.
It's worked out that males who sacrifice their bodies,
uh,
to this have more offspring than males who don't see.
You see the evolution from him being prayed just because he's prayed to it being
an actual part of the whole sexual situation.
So the next time someone tells you that evolution is the survival of the
fittest,
what are you going to tell them?
Fitness has a survival,
has nothing to do with the price of cheese.
That that's only one of the ways.
Okay.
Now the next strategy of females,
the first is to get resources.
The second strategy is for females to try to find the male with the best jeans.
And so that she,
uh,
her offspring are,
have good genes and are very successful.
So,
uh,
there's a whole lot of aspects to this and one is she has to be able to control
which may was fertilizing her genes.
So the more separated the male and the female,
when you spew out into the ocean,
eggs and sperm says no control whatsoever.
The closer that you come,
uh,
the male and the female come to each other,
the more control that the female has.
And one of the interesting ways of looking at this as internal fertilization as
in humans.
Uh,
it is,
it is among other things a strategy for female,
uh,
control.
So internal fertilization and internal growth of the fetus has a lot of
advantages.
It protects the fetus,
the fetus allows them other to provide nutrition and waste removal continuously,
et cetera.
But there are also this aspect of the female control strategy.
Uh,
generally if a female won't allow a meeting,
it doesn't happen.
The female doesn't allow it,
then ray passed happen.
We'll talk about a rape later in humans.
As you know,
females have a vulva and that's the Latin word for Valve Shaman open it,
she can close it.
And that's the whole idea.
So if the female wants to mate,
she gets excited and she lubricates.
And the purpose of the lubrication is to ease,
penetration and ease the sexual act.
Behavioral,
she's also siphon from the beginning.
She's receptive,
she assumes a proper posture and everything goes just fine.
But if these things,
if she doesn't want to do it and these things don't happen,
there's no lubrication.
There's no assumption of the proper posture which is necessary for internal
fertilization.
Uh,
then,
uh,
it's very hard for the mail to intermit and probably sexual intercourse won't
happen in a real rape,
say among humans.
The vent,
the vagina does not lubricate.
And that's why there's so much,
uh,
lacerating and tearing of the vaginal walls.
It's why it's so dangerous because it's part of the human female strategy to
control what males inseminate her is to not lubricate.
But if she's forced,
uh,
that can be a lot of damage done to her.
So how does a female,
no,
which male has the best genes which mail to allow to inseminate her?
She has to either watch a competition or,
or see the male in some way or know the outcome of some competition that she
doesn't see by say,
detecting a males a position in a status hierarchy.
And so in some birds,
like flamingos is a beautiful movie of Flamingos doing this,
which I don't have time to show,
uh,
that can be a hundred or so males can gather together and start dancing.
It's what a Lek.
And many of you may have heard of it or seen on national geographic movies,
the males dance back and forth,
back and forth.
They showed their coordination.
They show how perfect their feathers are.
They showed their stamina because they're there.
They're doing this for quite a long time.
And again,
the female stand around on the outside and try to notice a male who's a good
dancer,
good long,
strong,
well coordinated dancer and then she chooses him and goes off and mates.
And by choosing these males that are not,
you know,
not creaking around,
uh,
she presumed that she's getting a mail with the good,
with good genes.
Another way that,
uh,
that,
um,
the females get to choose a good male is by choosing males who have buy in
species where males fight as part of mail strategy.
Then the females choose the winners that males may fight and you set up a
dominance hierarchy,
but there's nothing says that the female has to choose the top dog.
Maybe she wants his middle dog or bottom dog.
But in general and species,
females choose the top dog.
They,
they,
they know the result of for a variety of ways the dominance fights and the
female then chooses the top dog and in the mail fights the,
the winner gets,
gets the female or maybe gets a whole Harem of females and the loser may get
absolutely nothing.
Well,
the females are very happy to join,
uh,
the winners Harem.
Why is that?
Because once that starts in a species,
that means that mail has some genes which allow him to win these fights.
He's,
he's big,
he's strong,
he's vicious.
He has sharp teeth.
It's a violent character and therefore he is successful in these battles and the
female wants her young to also once being in this evolutionary sense of if she
does that,
she passes on her jeans.
The female wants her offspring to have these characteristics of being able to
win a fight.
He of being very violent,
so she will choose the most violent male,
the winner of these battles to father her children because then they then the
odds are that they will also become these big,
strong violent males into what happens in this case is
in evolution,
males may start fighting and once the female select the fighters,
then both male and female reproductive strategy colludes in increasing the
violence a little bit in every generation and so it's very as the male and
female violence colluding in male on male violence.
Okay.
What else does evolution do?
Well,
if the males are fighting each other and reproductive success depends on winning
these fights,
then males will tend to get larger.
And uh,
you get a large male.
Humans,
chimpanzees male is larger than the female and that's helps them in the fights.
But it also opens up a second strategy for reproductive success.
Oh three,
if we have time.
The second strategy for reproductive success and that is that the male is now
bigger than the female and he can start coercing the female.
So he may not have to fight the males.
He can just coerce,
fight with and coerce,
uh,
this,
smaller female.
And then guess what happens if that gets into a species that the males start
cursing the females?
What does,
uh,
what does an evolutionarily wise female to do?
She chooses a male who was most successful at coursing females because again,
her children will then inherit those genes,
which will allow them to successfully coerce females and get more reproduction
and have more offspring.
So again,
we see that not only are male and female reproductive strategies cooperating in
an increase in male on male violence,
they also cooperate an increasing male on female violence.
It's really quite an interesting way of looking at things and explains,
starts to explain some of this violence that we see in human interactions.
Now the great,
we belong to the great ape,
uh,
line of evolution and it seems that our line of evolution seems to specialize in
male and female violence and consider rape.
So lot of s political correctness about use of the word great,
but I'm going to do it in a straight biological sense.
As rape is the coercion of an unwilling female into intercourse.
Outside of mammals,
there are only a very few species where rape occurs.
Scorpion flies or one of the best known examples.
Normal sex occurs when a male offers a female,
a dead insects or other food mass.
She's getting resources from him after she accepts,
she allows copulation to proceed,
um,
uh,
and it goes smoothly.
Sometimes.
However,
sex happens in quite a different way.
A male without an offering can ambush the female.
And she clearly is trying to escape.
And the whole time he's got genital class papers to try to grab onto her and
she's trying to get away and,
and push him away,
fly away.
And in your reading,
there's a description of,
of this rape of Scorpion fly.
We don't have to go further with it.
Invertebrates rapes occur in several species of docs.
And in mammals there are only three species where rape is routine.
Elephant seals,
orangutans,
and humans.
Rape occurs occasionally in three other mammals,
species,
chimpanzees,
how old her mom,
monkeys,
and gorillas when they're captive,
it has not been observed in the wild.
So this is really quite striking.
So of the six species,
a mammalian species in which rape has been observed,
five of those are,
are the great.
Eight are,
are apes and sorry,
one is a monkey.
The six species of primates where it's been observed,
uh,
for our great apes like us.
So those statistics are way out of the range of chance.
There was something special about ape evolution that has led to this emphasis on
a violent relationship between males and females.
And most likely it is the extreme unavailability of eggs.
So it's an extremely rare and Matt and in the Great Apes,
it's extremely rare to find a female who has an egg ready to be fertilized.
Why?
Well,
first primates take many years to become sexually mature in chimps and humans.
It's around 12 to 13 years before a female,
uh,
can obviate an egg.
So,
and then primate mothers have these long gestation periods,
eight months in chimps,
nine months in humans.
And so just counting gestation and the recovery from childbirth females can have
at most one young a year,
which means one egg available for fertilization in a whole year,
but then the females lactate.
And you'll probably know about,
uh,
lactational Amen area that when a female is lactating and the baby is sucking on
the nipple,
uh,
hormones are released and the female does not.
A lactate does not awfully late,
again,
the average for chimpanzees about another four years in which the female,
uh,
feeds breastfeeds,
the infant.
And so she doesn't come into fertility again.
And then they sometimes stay with their young,
uh,
even longer time.
So the average birth interval for chimpanzees is five and a half years.
That means for any female,
there's one egg every five and a half years ready to be fertilized.
Uh,
Jay,
that's Jane Goodall's number of Japanese groups as it's six years for
orangutans,
it's eight years.
And gorilla females have a baby about once every 10 years.
So this is an extreme dearth of eggs to get fertilized.
You have a chimp community.
They say 40,
45 to 55 individuals,
something like that,
maybe 10 or 12.
This is a big community,
10 or 12 sexually mature males,
about the same number of females,
um,
uh,
non mature males and females.
And of those then given the very long period,
there's probably gonna be one or two females in that whole year who are going to
be fertile and in estrus ready to get fertilized.
So these males spend the whole year in terms of their reproductive evolution,
spend the whole year setting themselves up to have that one to inseminate that
one egg.
That's available in that whole year.
You can imagine there's going to be a huge amount of competition,
a huge amount of violence,
uh,
among the males.
And as we've seen that male male violence then spills over to male,
female violence
within this group.
Uh,
we,
we belong to an order called a primates as you know,
and within this group,
monkeys are fairly distant relatives,
but the rest of the great apes are the great apes are fairly close.
And you can see there's a lot of similarities.
Um,
this isn't jokes about the singles bar even in biology,
to have some sense of humor still last.
Now this is another professor at Yale and I always ask students,
you know,
he got too many advisees.
So I asked them,
you know,
wouldn't you rather go to this guy?
And you know,
he looks very fatherly and kind and everything.
Well,
that's an orangutan and of the,
of the great apes,
it's as far distant from humans as the most distant species and yet looks pretty
much,
you know,
you can empathize with that,
uh,
as,
as almost a human being.
It doesn't take a lot of evolution to go between these two.
There are five species of great apes.
That's a young guy.
This is 50 this is a timescale that 15 million years ago there was one line of
evolution coming up from long time ago and the first event was that Uranga tans
split off the tree,
the tree split and one branch became orangutans.
Then about 10 million years ago another,
it was another split and gorillas went off.
A group went off and became gorillas.
Then about 6 million years ago,
another group that came off and they evolved into humans.
Most recent split is about 2 million years ago and gave two species very similar
species,
chimpanzees and Bonobos.
The farther distant the split is,
the more of there's been times to evolve differently.
So an orangutan who has that nice guy is very distant from the other species.
So that's,
that's our family tree and the difference this,
this is a fairly recent split here and the genetic difference between these
three species,
between any pair of those three species is about one and a half percent.
We,
if you draw out the DNA sequence for a,
for a chimpanzee and a human,
and look at the base pairs and are very hundred 98 or 99 will be identical in
one or two will be different.
So we're extremely similar genetically.
Uh,
now what does this difference mean?
One and a half,
2%.
We don't have the foggiest idea of what it means.
Obviously,
you know,
it can look at a chimpanzee and say,
hey,
it ain't human and their behavior is different and they can't speak and all
kinds of things.
But genetically there's not that big of a difference.
So I wouldn't draw any particular conclusions from the genetics yet.
We're,
this is a rapidly evolving field and we're going to learn an awful lot very
quickly.
And when doesn't know what the conclusions are going to turn out to be.
One thing which may be solid is that if you look between a ma,
you know,
females have two x chromosomes and males have an x and y chromosome.
So you can have to,
what is the genetic distance between a human male and a human female?
And guess what?
One and a half percent.
So whatever you think of the difference,
a genetic distance of those species,
you pretty much at this current stage of our knowledge have to think the same as
the genetic difference between a human male and a human female.
So that's,
that's grist for your thinking.
Um,
each of the great ape species has evolved at different social system to organize
reproduction and all.
But one have an awful lot of violence associated with it.
Orangutans are the least social,
uh,
vapes.
The males and the females generally,
uh,
stay apart and the mother and the child or the only stable social unit,
the,
the offspring stay with the mother until adolescence.
Very much like the chimpanzee story.
And,
and,
and like the human story,
it's about 10 years before the young separates.
And for most of the eight years between birth,
the mother has no interest in,
in males at all,
no interest in sex at all.
She doesn't really come very close to them.
There are two kinds of orangutan males.
There's a large one and a small one.
The big males are about 200 pounds.
Uh,
the females in the small nails are less than half that size,
about 90 pounds.
Uh,
there's this,
the small mail develops normally up to adolescence and then just stops
developing further,
doesn't develop the characteristics of,
of,
of the full mail does grow beard crests,
uh,
of the hair,
throat pouches and etc. They remain looking like adolescents,
but they are completely fertile and have a normal compliment of testosterone.
They're sexually totally capable and they can stay as this in this adolescent
stage for up to 18 years,
maybe longer.
But that's the most that anyone has observed them.
And they probably don't grow into a big male until the dominant male in the
region has died or is too weak to defend himself.
So the females,
uh,
always wonder when they have a choice.
They always want to meet with the big males because the big males are more
successful.
And it's the old story that females mate with males of the type that are already
successful because that is good for the genes that her children get in the
meeting,
uh,
between,
a female and a big male,
sexist,
very relaxed.
Uh,
it has taken on a languorous quality and an erotic quality.
There's not a great rush.
Meetings can begin with oral or manual manipulation of the partners' Genitalia.
And it can be initiated by either the male or by the female.
And when they finally do engage in intercourse,
um,
they do it often face to face missionary style.
And it takes her about it,
about as long as it takes humans an average of 11 minutes and up to half an hour
just in case you want to compare.
Now these big males are ponderous,
they can't move fast,
whereas the females are alive and they,
they can,
they can go pretty fast.
So you know,
the female was choosing the mail cause we didn't want them.
She could be gone and there's no way that he could catch her.
But what about the small males?
They uh,
they are not attracted to females,
but they have,
they have one advantage.
They're small and they're fast and they can run fast and they can catch females.
So that's what mother evolution has,
has done.
They try to catch and rape the females.
And the females are usually,
as I said,
alone with their young.
And if they're found by a single buy,
one of these small males,
they're chased.
And sometimes they get caught.
And then the females show fear and they struggle to escape.
And the males sometimes strike them or bite them.
And the females scream and the young there,
they're dependent.
The young scream,
the females bite back,
they hit,
they pulled the hair of the males,
uh,
while the copulation is going on.
And that lasts not more than 10,
10 minutes.
So how common is this?
A different?
Orangutans are very hard to see.
They live in a part of Borneo.
It's hard to get to and they're,
they're very hard to see.
But,
so there's different studies coming to different conclusions.
Uh,
one,
a theologist found that about a third one,
third of a Orang mutations of off some degree of forcing of the female by the
male.
Japanese observers reported that 88% of the copulations where rapes and that
these were the severe kind,
a Dutch observer judged half the copulations to be raped.
So these are not rare events.
They're standard part of the rang of Tang sexual,
uh,
strategy.
There's a lot of examples where,
uh,
orangs are close enough to humans that apparently a lot of those same sexual
signals are passing.
Uh,
a woman primatologist who ran primatology research in,
in,
in Borneo,
uh,
talked about in neuron who had lived with humans for a lot of his life.
So it was very acculturated to humans.
And one day,
apparently he raped one of the female cooks,
the rang Tang,
the mail or ring raped,
one of the human female cooks at the camp.
And the parents are complete rape with penetration and everything.
And as you know,
uh,
rape is a big embarrass,
a big embarrassment for the female as well as the male.
But in this case,
and this an Indonesia,
uh,
the husband very unusually took it quite easily.
The husband said that since the rapist was not human,
the rape should not provoke shame a rage.
He said,
why should my wife,
Rebekah,
my wife,
will I be concerned?
It wasn't demand.
So there's all kinds of stories that I don't have time to tell you about this.
Uh,
okay.
Now,
why doesn't evolution,
uh,
just keep the males and females together?
Probably food density.
There's food is hard to get in and individuals have to forage alone to find
enough food vape fortune pairs.
What they found would not be enough for two of them.
Now,
well,
gorillas live in a region and have an ecology that they have more food available
to them.
So they live in somewhat larger groups and in gorillas,
the female stick close to the mail.
Each male,
a big silverback male can have a Harem of say three to four.
Uh,
females in these Harem thinks I spend most of their time.
Just the few of them together.
They're quiet,
they're relaxed,
they're affectionate with each other.
The,
the,
the troop is stable.
Uh,
with the,
the one silver back three or four females and whatever young,
uh,
they have very little aggressiveness of between the males and the females or
female to female just hardly happens.
But as I said before,
if one male was controlling three to four females,
that means there's two to three males that don't have any mates whatsoever.
And what does evolution going to do with those bachelor bowels?
Again at eight.
Nice.
The mail.
So they,
the gorillas traveled through the jungle,
resting some eating,
some,
the fruits,
the roots,
the shoots.
These bachelor males followed the troop on the uphill side and just wait until
the silver back is not watching.
Then they charge down.
They make,
can make a fair amount noise so often the silverback notices and goes over and
beats the hell out of the guy.
And he retreats again.
But every so often he's successful.
He,
the male is with another female or off.
Never very far away,
but a little way it goes down.
What does he do?
He charges downhill.
So he gets up a lot of speed.
He charges right at a female with a young,
he grabs the young immediately,
uh,
smashes it on the ground and kills it,
runs away.
It doesn't try to do anything.
It just kills the young of the female.
Now,
what does the female do at the females are the,
these are very smart.
They are the great apes,
so they're very smart.
They recognize each other's individuals.
They have long memories.
So you would expect that this female would remember this male,
the rest of her life and fear him,
hate him,
avoid him.
In fact,
the opposite happens.
What happens is the female within a few days generally leaves the silver back
that was supposed to be guarding her and goes with the single male and they go
off and have a consort ship.
What the message that the male is delivering to the female is,
look,
you've put a huge investment into this infant and now it's wasted.
That guy can't protect you.
You know,
he has too many females.
He's too old.
He's too big and slow.
He can't protect you.
I can call.
You can get,
you can stay with him and get pregnant again,
and I'm going to come down and kill your next baby too.
So if you want to reproduce,
you come off with me.
Of course,
none of this is verbal.
This is an evolutionary story.
I hope.
I hope you understand that,
you know,
they're not meditating this stuff tonight that I'm saying.
Uh,
and so what you notice is in a few days,
this female leaves and goes with the male that has just killed her young and,
and starts reproducing with that one that may be stable and last a long time or
another male may come by and in a few months,
uh,
separate him,
separate them.
So again,
these are not isolated incidents.
Uh,
Diane Fossey,
uh,
had data on about 50 infants,
38% of them died.
I went before they were three and 37% of those were from infanticide.
About one infant in seven dies from infanticide in each of the female gorilla
she studied,
had at least one infant that was killed by infanticide.
Soon the gorillas,
the females are trapped in this vortex of male initiated violence.
At any moment,
a male may come crashing through the forest and,
and kill her young.
And the best way for her to prevent this is to go off with that male.
She needs protection.
She leads lives in a world of baby killers and she needs a protection from them.
Chimpanzees who are going down the list of species and we won't get time to
finish,
but chimpanzees have yet another solution to this primate reproductive problem
of very,
very scarce eggs.
Unlike orangs and gorillas,
the males are not solitary,
but related.
Males spend their lifetime together as a community.
Chimps live in groups of about 40 individuals with a dozen or so,
a adult males.
And a similar number of adult females.
As with the Orangutans,
uh,
the chimp female spend most of their time alone with their young,
and they're not separated from their young until there are several years old,
really into adolescence.
And so first they hold them,
they're not physically separated for several years and then for several years
they're not out of sight.
And then for several more years than not out of voice contact.
So it's really very,
very tight bonding between mother and,
and,
and children.
The males defend a rather large territory,
um,
numbers of square kilometers in which they range in which the,
the females range and the males spend their time searching for food patrolling.
Uh,
the board is the territory and they're often with other males.
This patrolling is off,
is,
uh,
is a,
is a bunch of males together and they go around checking on the females to see
which ones have come into estrus or if any have come into estrus.
As I mentioned,
the females come into estrus only about once every six years after their last
young was born.
They have a 35 day cycle,
very similar to humans and our sexually receptive for about 15 of these days in
each of their monthly cycles.
Her fertility increases during these 15 days and she's most fertile the last two
or three days of this receptive period.
The females do an interesting thing.
I've ever been to a zoo and looked at chimpanzee females,
but do you see
big red rump if they're,
if they're fertile,
it looks rather disgusting to humans.
And I've been looking for a picture of it an amazingly,
it's such a striking thing.
I cannot find a really good picture of this,
but you go to a zoo,
it's very,
very obvious.
They,
they're,
uh,
of the cold anal genital swelling.
They advertise their estrus oppositely to humans.
Humans keep the Astra secret needed.
The male or the female knows whether they're in estrus chimpanzees advert.
Everybody knows.
Now why did they do that?
Well,
what happens is when a female comes into estrous,
the mail's been waiting all year for this.
The males congregate together.
And what are the males start doing competing for the female?
They're fighting.
The dominant male arrives and it's clear who's dominant.
So the females advertise as a way of inciting male violence that they want to be
able to choose the dominant male,
the ones that are great fighting form.
So they say,
Hey,
I'm an estrus,
or you guys come and fight and I'm going to sit there and,
and,
and choose the best of you.
Which in this case means the most violent of you.
But unfortunately in this situation,
all these males are not only fighting with each other,
but they're trying to get it to females.
So the females are,
are heard about,
they have to run around to escape the end.
The cloud that clashes with the males.
They regularly receive quite a lot of,
of,
of wounds when they chased or they try to climb up trees to escape this,
sometimes they fall out of trees.
Uh,
and uh,
they had their young Windom and the young something to cling to them.
And then if they,
if the mother's fault,
the kids fall,
it's a very,
very dangerous,
uh,
unpleasant time.
And the,
the,
uh,
the violence is so great that when a male approaches a female,
she doesn't know whether he's coming to be,
uh,
you know,
to try to meet with her or to be violent toward her.
Because you'll read in the reading how the males have a long history of being
violent to the females.
It's a way of counting them so that when they're in this melee,
when their estrous,
no male approaches them,
they don't resist.
If they do try to resist,
he does a lot of violence on them.
So the male has to,
when the mail comes and wants to mate with the female,
he has to signal to her,
don't run away.
I'm not going to try to beat you up.
And he has,
this is,
sorry,
these orangutans,
gorilla chimpanzee with
her young,
uh,
this is the,
this male is inspecting the female that not only is a red rump,
but there's,
there's odors,
chemicals,
and he's trying to see what,
what the status of her,
her cycle is.
Uh,
and this is a male displaying letting a female,
no.
Uh,
that,
that this is the sexual,
uh,
engagement and humans have been known to do the same thing.
This is a picture from Borneo.
The same sort of advertising was pretty much the same message.
And here's an incredible photographs.
And I saw,
I don't know,
should I leave that on the board?
I get in trouble leaving things like that on that
for too long.
Um,
okay.
Now [inaudible] so in this great Malay,
there's great violent man.
There's all the males they're trying to get at this female.
Um,
if a male does it,
let's say that Alpha males or fighting with someone else and the females alone
for a minute,
the male,
uh,
any male that's around,
rushes in,
but he's not going to have a lot of time before the other males notice what's
going on in rush into,
to separate them because they're all competing for,
to inseminate,
uh,
that egg.
So the males have a very short time in which to complete the copulation and
ejaculation occurs an hour of just 15 seconds with only 8.8 pelvic thrusts.
I think those are very important numbers you should know.
But the females make up in quantity.
What they don't get in quality,
they appear,
and there's a story behind this,
but they appeared to be quite promiscuous and their sex partners and the
community followed by Jane Goodall in each estrous cycle.
Each female had at least one bout of intercourse with every male.
So all the males are getting some chance at having intercourse.
The average six encounters a day,
but don't get excited.
It's still only a minute.
And a half at their rate.
And in each monthly sexual cycle,
they have about a hundred or so bouts of intercourse.
So there's a lot of sexuality.
Do females have Oregon orgasms?
Not known debates about it,
but not,
no.
All right.
I guess,
um,
our time is running out.
Uh,
we will continue on Thursday and I'll set up sections in between and a,
any questions?
Can I stay after every lecture for as long as necessary?
If people want to come down and ask questions.